what's your go-to comfort food in Japan
I don't think I've ever asked you this
man go-to comfort food like you're
you're not concerned about calories you
just want something that's kind of quick
but it's what is what's the go-to comt
food for you I mean it's it's tough
right there's actually there's a two-
part answer one is if I'm craving
something Western because I miss that
aspect of my life it'll probably be
Mexican food I just love Mexican food
and um if it's the Japanese side it's
Ramen Ramen and these are such
unoriginal answers I know like Mak these
are just great comfort foods and like a
tonko Ramen like with spinach and like
it it's good it really anytime after 2:
p.m. until 4:00 a.m. I would eat that
any anytime and then Mexican food is
just goated oh yeah we always get
Mexican food places it's it's so weird
because Mexican food was never really
part of our palet growing up in the UK
it was so hard to find a Mexican food
restaurant uh and now you know it's it's
weird growing up and now I have cravings
about Cuisines for Cuisines that I never
oh my mom used to always make those uh
Old El Paso starter kids those are
great hard shell
ones also ones too those are goed though
I I still have cravings for this
becausee I still remember the ads and I
my mom used to make the fajita one all
the time and I used think they taste
soang these are great these are still
goated
all Mexican style remember the you can
like throw in just a bunch of chicken
and bunch of peppers you're like man I
feel kind of good about this like I
don't feel awful I mean I still
sometimes do like breakfast burritos in
the morning absolutely yeah with like
some chicken and spinach and stuff like
it's it's goated but when whenever I go
to uh whenever I go to California I'm
sure remed how goddamn good Mexican food
that it's really unfair that breakfast
burrito we had that was amazing cuz I
feel like a lot of breakfast burritos my
problem is is that a lot of the time uh
all the ingredients don't really blend
well sometimes the egg is too scrambled
or the bacon is too overpowering and so
it's really easy to get a breakfast
bagel it's just like kind of like egg
and bread sorry breakfast Brito and so
but in California man oh there you go
yeah they figured it out so hard I do
miss the totinos pizzas from when I was
these were like
79 little ones they're like they're like
this big you know they're like not the
little talking about pizza rolls yeah
pizza rolls also totinos but the totinos
pizzas were I think that sustained me
through college is it tortinos or
totinos I don't know it's either
Tostinos or toos right it's maybe we
never even had this by the way but it's
uh yeah is it totinos yeah it's totinos
totinos yeah to I know my pizza but even
not the pizza rolls themselves because
those were uh delectable snack but the
the old 79 cent pizzas have you seen
this have you seen this one what
inan has one B Clan orange chicken
totina pizza roll I'm never moving I did
see someone on Tik Tok make a breakfast
burito with that and it was saddest like
thing no I me off of totinos completely
style chicken pizza that's just not what
I'm looking for but yeah I do miss
Cravings but you know what I I think
Japan is one of the great places on
Earth that you can really go outside
your house and find 25 different things
to eat true for really affordable prices
abolutely we're pretty lucky in that
regard my brother's visiting right now
and he's uh just amazed at how cheap
everything is and I'm like well be in
mind the Yen also the Yen keeps tanking
it did tank a good time yeah I was like
you you have a very good rate right now
every week I'm like oh it's a new record
low that's that's great all my went to
ichiran and he loved it ichiran is not
bad CH I I love ichiran I think it's
still good I know Joey hates it think
smug he look over the noodles are not it
tastes great it's the most five out of
10 thing ever well still I like Ramen
but I think McDonald's of ramen it is
which I it's a comfort but I'll never
line up for it these people who [__]
line up for 40 minutes oh psycho the
[__] stop yeah the the big thing about
America though that surprised me cuz we
just came back from Las Vegas Los
Angeles was my God the prices of food is
insane though I went to a sandwich place
and I was feeling pretty badass I was
like don't worry guys I got it and then
uh we got five sandwiches and these were
just like normal Italian but some mom
and pop st they were very good
they they were very good but and then I
I I was like I have a card and I thumped
it down on the table like I was the king
of all creation and then it was like
beep beep and I was like what's going on
over there and they're like sir it's
been declined and I was like let me take
a look at it $125 for five sandwiches
$125 $25 sandwich it was 20 to two 20 to
$22 per sandwich and I didn't even
include the tip yet plus taxes and then
of course somebody what the [__] was in
a caveal that's what I thought it was to
be fair it was some fancy Italian one
well it was they baked their own bread
was just something give [__] we're in La
we could we listen we can go Las Vegas
la la pric that makes sense and it was
because you added the brata to each
sandwich which was like an extra $5
which is way way of a price of well
anyway I was like try this card please
and then they were like it's been
declined I was like here's all my money
that I brought and then you know I was
embarrassed I couldn't believe
$125 for for five sandwiches that's like
almost 20,000 yen it isn't that insane
yeah we did we did discussion of like
how that would be a full-on restaurant
meal yeah it'd be like an omaka like a
recommended Sushi course for that kind
with like alcohol and a bu it is absurd
well I think uh yeah every everything
was so expensive yeah I feel bad for my
Americans out there I understand your
pain there was now I now I know why
every American just like whenever they
come to Japan it's like a kid in a
County store they're like I could buy
everything this is only $3 we had a a
night free in Los Angeles and um we we
were going to go out to
uh can I tell the
story we we go out to this uh we found
this cool gaming bar well Pete found it
I found it and uh it was like 20 minutes
away we like yeah [__] it let's go let's
do it we go over to this gaming
bar and uh it's in like kind of a I
would I would say it's a little sketchy
area it wasn't like it was uh it was it
wasn't like the best anyway so the's
security at the door of this bar and we
go in and he's like we for a Barcade I'm
sorry what who's going into a Barcade
and causing troubles okay so you know we
go in and uh we're sitting there and we
just had like a such a long talk with
this Uber driver as well that went on
for ages so I was I felt like I was like
I was like okay let's play some games
and it looks amazing there's so many
like old retro games there's a giant
list of craft beers and food and I was
like oh okay and it's all kind of tucked
behind this glass where you can see it
all you can do anything you want for the
next six or seven hours yeah and we met
with this kind of like what I can only
describe as uh what's the what's the old
guy from Breaking Bad called again Mike
Mike it's like a mikees kind of security
guard sitting there and obious obviously
we're in LA and it's very common where
they'll ask for your ID yeah uh and you
know normally you can kind of get away
with whatever ID you have so I but I
happen to have my passport and I show it
and and Pete you show your Japanese card
he's like what is this I was like well
it's a nice from Japan that is a nation
he was like I'm going to need to see
something with letters yeah he said he
said something with letters and I I
point out to I'm like oh you know this
you know the date of birth is is right
there in numbers numbers are Universal
uh it's says date of birth in English on
and he was doing all the stuff he was
holding it up there's not even a light
to hold it up to he's like in this dark
piece like I've never seen nothing like
with these squeak and I was like there's
also letters on the top this says nation
and like date of birth yeah it's written
in English it's written in English and
he was like I'm not going to let you in
unless you have your passport and I was
like well now you're doubting that I'm
American I was like where do you think
I'm coming
from or it's it's either you about your
high school years now yeah like he's
bullying me yeah he's like I can't let
you in unless I scan it I was like scan
what like what do you mean like like not
to you know not to be mean but you don't
luck under
21 was on the fence 20 to 22 is when in
England it's like Challenge 25 rule uh
there's no such thing in the UK of if
you look old they're not going to
[__] old well if you look experienced
they're not going to [__] ches season
3 um but no I was quickly humbled and
there was nothing on Earth we could do
show my passport what the [__] he denied
all sorts of my other cards and and
different you know health insurance and
he was like unless it's got letters I
can't scan it and we were like all right
so we had to turn away from this
glorious yeah a blinking shining thing
and I took you to the worst fried
chicken place and all of we this sports
bar that looked kind of cool and it had
like a retro sign of punch out outside
it l really cool and the lighting was
awesome we we sit down and I got the
chicken tenders as was a child wood you
got you got a chicken burger I did and
uh they were just it was like what $15
for this thing and it was they were just
like like frozen nuggets it was horrible
it was the worst I I found out something
by the way so I felt so I was like don't
worry Connor I'll pay for he was very
annoyed he was very up down and they
were like it's been declined I was like
I was no I I this one it worked and uh
we got our thing you know what I found
out all of that was vegan that's why it
was oh so it wasn't a chicken blame the
vegans find because I was so upset that
I picked the worst chicken spot on the
planet you wanted the reason you wanted
I wanted to know how could this exist
with chicken that this bad that makes so
much sense it tastes a lot better now it
was like it was like it was a chicken
tender and it came out looking like a
like a cylinder and I was like what the
[__] is this I into yeah and I bought
into it and it was like crumbled I was
like what the [__] is this and I was in
full defense mod I was like you know a
lot of chickens they look like that it's
just the different cuts it's just
American chicken you know it's we've
seen that before it was a square and I
was like H you know the thigh these days
you know and so they roed them up yeah
but uh kind of redemption Arc that they
were trying to give Chicken okay that
that makes me feel chicken place I like
it a lot more now does it make it better
no it was still bad food I
mean the fried pickles were good which
is a thing I wish that Japan would adopt
and the UK the pickles just deep fried
I'm like this is great I love it just
deep fried it's just great yeah that was
a horrible horrible um $100 we spent
trying to go to one Barcade yeah $100 I
mean two Ubers plus the the meal and
you're looking at like and we didn't
even do
anything so it was um my fault yeah
sounds like La so damn how' you find Las
Vegas I hated it no I'm kidding it was
Vegas I
think I think I said this on the
previous episode Vegas is like a two-day
thing I think four days was just too
long in Vegas this is 100% the case I
feel like if you're gonna go and the big
thing is hey what happens in Vegas St in
Vegas let's gamble I think the Friday
Saturday finish Saturday night go back
or Sunday morning is but I think
anything longer than those 48 Hours you
you just hate the experience the end but
um personally speaking I love gambling
and I love I love the idea of of risk in
it allll where I'm like you know all on
black and they're like you lose or I'm
playing Blackjack and I don't know the
rules that well I'm like I'll stay and
they're like sir it's eight I'm like I
like to live d double and then he's like
you lose but it was so much fun for me
to to be a lose money yeah to lose money
uh with with you know vigor
yeah go with style you have to go in the
mindset of I'm going to lose this money
and that is what I did yeah I did lose
we did lose well the one night he he got
very annoyed at me one night um because
we I'd been losing all night I was like
guys One Last Hand we bet it
all and he had just won a big hand he
did he just won a big hand and I was
like guys if we're going to leave we
should just put all our [__] money on
the table and if we lose we lose and if
we win it'll be an epic story of course
we lose of course we lost immediately
immediately it was like the deal got 21
it wasn't even fun we didn't get to play
it we didn't even get to play it because
Vegas has this horrible system where the
dealer gets to basically like win
instantly insta kill it's it's [__]
don't I mean generally gambling in Vegas
is just a terrible idea in general but
unless you play craps no crap that is a
a a sport of Kings because you control
the outcome you don't you you don't know
how math Works gambling works I'm
telling you that's way more skill don't
ever oh my God please do not listen to
this this is absolutely incorrect this
is not Prof this is gambling is never a
good thing you should never do it but if
you want to have fun craps is fun with
friends if you to money control the odds
is by counting cards which is illegal
it's
illegal illegal if you get caught no
it's no no no it's also not you can't
they just ask you to leave they can just
ban you it's not illegal though they can
they can ban you and they can make you
illegal for you to uh enter foot into
casinos but it's not illegal to count
cards you that's like saying it's
illegal to be good at playing like
American football like you know there's
they well because that's essentially
what you're doing like you're saying hey
you are too good at this you that is
illegal right but they have to make it
fair no all jokes aside uh I just like
craps because it's the most interactive
game you can play but that's the problem
the more interactive the game the faster
it is to uh lose money yeah I feel
that's a bit stalk SC
but I mean I will Los money because it's
fun but like the thing about craps that
I do like is that you can put a pretty
minimum bet down and just enjoy the
atmosphere of the table and not say I'm
I swear it always stoms with a minimum
bet it always St for the when I go back
I'm going to get back that 10,000 I lost
no I'm kidding but I broke even on the
trip because I didn't invest a lot
because you set limits obviously and so
I I just kind of had fun with hanging
out with friends and so that was that
was a good experience but won't be going
back anytime worth more than any money
in the
world the real gambling was the friends
we made along the way at Le we didn't
lose the F we made one fun thing that
happened is that we we were doing craps
T night and this gentleman came over and
it was like he was locked in yeah he was
so serious every single turn he would
get the dice and he would line it up
perfectly and he'd put it on the exact
number he wanted for both Dice and he
would pinch it like this and he would
always throw it the same way wouldn't
say a word and wouldn't get excited
about anything m and uh he was winning a
lot and then uh he was just kind of like
zoned in next day I got a twitchcon I'm
about to go on this show and this
producer guy comes up and he starts
doing stuff and I was like oh the guy
from last night on the table what he was
that guy and he was so jovial and happy
and talking and I was it was just such a
different energy and I was like yeah you
you want everyone a lot of money last
night I like I was on a terar last night
man I was in the zone and I was like
whoa okay dude okay chill dude I just
love to imagine the dichotomy between
that guy who was like super [__]
serious and Pete just
going everyone everyone you're supposed
to like bring your own energy to it yeah
you're right I was doing that I was just
let's go and I was I was definitely it
was my birthday and it was I was
slightly inebriated I was possibly maybe
shouting repeatedly every 2 minutes
we're printing money here I may or may
not have been sh that and uh I went on a
pretty big tear though myself and so
it's very fun when it all goes well cuz
it's the game pays out a lot but then
it's verying when you lose oh it's very
measurable because the odds of getting
because the game is designed as such
that you have the highest odds of losing
and so it just keeps happening a lot of
times and then everyone just kind of
like oh it's the thrill of that one time
you you defy Thrill of the hunt but I I
also love Japanese kind of old style
gambling like hanafuda or chinin like
these are just fun games that even if
you don't invest money the game itself
is fun to play so I I that's where I
come from I guess I mean I like games
with Stakes well me too games it depends
how high the stakes are though you know
$25 no but I want a winner and I want a
loser yeah that's uh that's all that's
important